Nick youngin swaggy P is here and
draymond Green is going to give him the
jewelry and for Nick Young who was so
happy to get a Western Conference
championship Pat's
this is forever this is a ring that
signifies his participation on that
phenomenal team a year ago and while
he's always calm cool collected this is
still an emotional moment for any player
absolutely that's the very very special
[Applause]
dream on giving him the ring and Oracle
giving him the love he's eating it up at
me well well this [ __ ] he was the star
of the parade smoking jacket during the
parade
and Nick always has a smile on his face
and always was kind of a joyful presence
around the team and he's got the
championship ringing now every ring has
been given out Jim to everybody that won
the title a year ago but let's start all
over yeah it's exactly exactly but that
doesn't start for about a week and a
half
the Warriors yeah they want to build on
the game last night they were of thirty
nine to twelve at the end of one and led
wire-to-wire
against the lake DeMarcus Cousins and
Andre Iguodala will not fight tonight as
my Andrew Bogut has to start and ruin
Shaun Livingston didn't play last night